Путін цінує лояльність більше ніж
компетентність Це добре для українців Я
думаю що це справді відображає мафіозну
сутність Росії усі ці хлопці щось мають
один на одного
якщо Росія спричинить ядерну аварію на
АЗС це має розглядатися як порушення
статті п'ятої статуту НАТО
а потім Росія скаже нам ви ж не хочете
вести з нами ядерну Війну за шматок
Естонії чи Литви Ось у цьому небезпека
цього року Україна могла би виграти цю
війну а швидкість і ціна залежить від
Сполучених Штатів
пане ходжеса Як ви думаєте ситуація з
пвк Вагнер була постановочною Якщо так
то щось його отримає Росія
Що ж ми бачимо Зовсім не те що зазвичай
відбувається в армії яка вірить що вона
на шляху до перемоги це продемонструвало
багато тріщини проблем на вершині між
різними лідерами а також нездатність
Росії військово відповісти навіть на дії
пвк Вагнер коли колона рухалася на
північ через Воронич на Москву кілька
місяців тому британська розвідка заявила
що 95% російської армії нині задіяно в
Україні Отже в Росії більше нічого немає
це розкриває деякі реальні проблеми які
вони мають я припускаю що втрата 25
тисяч військових також буде болісною це
щонайменше дивно І звичайно є багато
речей про які Ніхто з нас насправді не
знає як Лукашенко почав у цьому
фігурувати як свого роду герой я не
думаю що це все постановка Я думаю що це
справді відображає мафі озну сутність
Росії усі ці хлопці щось мають один на
одного і вони готові застосовувати
насильству один проти одного коли це
необхідно мене вразило те що ніхто не
прийшов публічно на мітинг на підтримку
президента Путіна люди або мовчали або
чекали осторонь спостерігаючи що буде я
думаю це показало що у Володимира Путіна
зараз дійсно дуже-дуже крихка владна
позиція
[музика]
Як ви гадаєте що союзники понату та
Україна можуть Винести з цього Путін
зараз ослаблений чи зміцнився І що він
робити медалі
Я не бачу щоб хтось із російського боку
став міцнішим через цю ситуацію усі
тріщини всі проблеми всі розломи
всередині всієї Російської мафіозної
держави були оголені і я думаю що
багатьом урф нині може загрожувати
чистка або ж вони відчують сміливість
скоїти ще щось якщо побачиш що пригожину
все минеться інша річ яку ми повинні
Винести з цього ми маємо переосмислити
як ми оцінюємо здатність Путіна діяти я
не думаю що Путін тепер зможе довіряти
великій кількості своїх офіцерів і тому
коли йдеться про ядерну зброю чи
ескалацію війни Я думаю що західні
розвідувальні служби та наші уряди тепер
дивитися на Путіна крізь туризму і
намагатимуться зрозуміти Хто насправді
там керує цікаво чи залишиться щойгу
міністром оборони ходять чутки що так
тоді це доведе що Путін цінує лояльність
більше ніж компетентність Це добре для
українців бо ми не хочемо щоб Росія
отримала більш компетентне керівництво
для війни втрата 25 000 військових для
Російської сторони є великою проблемою
Якщо ця кількість 25 000 вагнерівців
близька до точної то вони зникнуть як
бойова сила з України деякі з них можуть
бути зараховані до складу збройних сил
РФ як солдати Але нікому з них не можна
буде довіряти тож єдині російські
підрозділи які мали Хоч якийсь тактичний
успіх зникли їх буде важко замінити
не збираються сидіти в Білорусі пригожин
не поїхав до Білорусі займатися
в'язанням Це все що викликає серйозне
занепокоєння Вони все ще становлять
небезпеку мабуть насамперед для Путіна
але Очевидно це все ще й небезпека
України
[музика]
одна з найбільших невідомих у цій
ситуації для мене це домовленості між
пригожиним Путіним Та лукашенком що вони
насправді одне одному запропонували про
що домовилися що запропонували пригожину
заколот був для пригожина шансом
позбутися того кого він ненавидить
найбільше щойгу але також ймовірно
отримати якусь величезну компенсацію
повідомляється що пвк Вагнер мають
розформувати а цих солдатів можуть
зарахувати до російських військ Я дуже
скептично до цього ставлюся Але якщо це
правда то є сумніваюся що багато цих
хлопців справді захочуть підписати
контракт тому що вони точно не отримують
тих самих переваг які отримували як
найманці і знають що їх відправлять у
бій як гарматне м'ясо тому я не вірю що
багато з них захочуть приєднатися до
російської армії рядовими сержантами
Нині багато людей заробляють великі
гроші на підприємствах Вагнера в Африці
бізнес-модель полягає у видобутку золота
і діамантів з африканських родовищ і на
цьому заробляє не лише пригожин тому я
буду дуже уважно стежити за військами
Вагнера в малі та Лівії зокрема тому що
саме там знаходиться більшість із них
тож це може бути доброю новиною для
України якщо як ви кажете частина
найкомпетентніших бійців більше не
воюватиме на боці Росії що це означатиме
для України чи є хоч найменша
вірогідність того що Путін сфокусується
на власних проблемах і використає це як
стратегію виходу з України
Путін може змінити наратив коли захоче
Так роблять диктатори автократи тому він
міг би змінити наратив про необхідність
повернути усіх додому і я сумніваюся що
ви побачите великі протести на вулицях
будуть люди які будуть незадоволені але
я сумніваюся що будуть протести
більшість росіян Як каже Тім Снайдер
завжди будуть під контролем якогось
ганстра Хто б це не був тому просто
намагаються продовжувати своє
повсякденне життя я не думаю що люди там
настільки емоційно прив'язані до того що
відбувається в Україні якщо у них немає
сина чи чоловіка чи брата який справді
там воює тому Путін міг би використати
це як привид Щоб змінити свій власний
наратив
а для України Перше українці усвідомили
що багато російських солдатів зараз
почали задавати собі питання про те що
відбувається навколо них чи справді вони
хочуть ризикувати бути вбитим або у
нівеченими у війні у якій вони програють
як приміром міністр оборони резніков
зробив на вихідних прямій звернення до
солдатів РФ через усілякі соцмережі СМС
із написом вам не треба тут Помирати
Ворог у Москві він не в Україні Я думаю
що це змусить замислитися багатьох тим
часом Україна буде продовжувати
Контрнаступ але українці мабуть
зрозуміли що російська сторона буде
відволікатися буде невизначеність у
команду
логістика буде перервана тому я вважаю
що Україна продовжить грати проти
слабшого суперника
наскільки вас хвилює наприклад ситуація
в Запоріжжі це залишається головним
питанням безпеки для українців і всіх у
регіоні чи не так
Я вважаю що всі ми справді маємо бути
дуже стурбовані тим що Росія все ще
контролює Запорізьку АЕС і те що ми
дійсно нічого не зробили щоб покарати
Росію після руйнування каховської дамби
є екологічною катастрофи спричиненої цим
ми все що говоримо про те що не хочемо
робити щось таке що спровокує Росія на
ескалацію але що ще вони не скоїли крім
використання ядерної зброї Тож ми маємо
висловити щодо цього чітку позицію якщо
в Запоріжжі станеться витік або якийсь
вибух то постраждає Туреччина всі країни
Чорного моря а також інші країни поблизу
в дуже великому радіусі тому я вважаю що
слід усіх поінформувати і переконатися
що Путін усвідомлює що це його
відповідальність він не зможе
звинуватити в цьому Україну що Звісно
Росія намагатиметься зробити
але які будуть наслідки НАТО нічого не
зробить це ж не той випадок коли надто
застосує п'яту статтю
двоє сенаторів виступили на вихідних і
фактично запропонували що саме це має
статися Що це має розглядатися як стаття
п'ята якщо Росія навмисно зруйнує або
спричинить ядерну аварію на Запорізькій
АЕС і цей зачепить країни НАТО Я не знаю
чи дійде до цього чи 31 країна
погодиться на це але факт у тому що люди
на дуже високих рівнях справді шукають
способи дати зрозуміти Росії що це буде
не прийнятним І що їм доведеться
заплатити за це дуже дорогу ціну це ще
одна причина того що ми повинні
прискорити надання Україні всього що і
потрібно для перемоги Я би хотів аби
адміністрація США сказала Дуже чітко це
для блага усіх західних країн щоб
Україна виграла І що ми більше не будемо
виправдовуватися щодо того скільки
палива спалюють абрамси або скільки часу
потрібно щоб підготувати пілотів f16 чи
що не вистачить А такамс це неправда
давайте покінчимо з цим цього року
Україна могла би виграти цю війну і
швидкість та ціна залежить від
Сполучених Штатів
щодо військової мобільності якби
існувала загроза для союзників по НАТО
чи вірите Ви що сили НАТО зможуть швидко
дістатися до своїх союзників на Східному
фланзі якщо на цьому напрямку
знадобляться значні ресурси
у нас є сили НАТО Розгорнуті в Естонії і
аж до Болгарії Отже там є війська Але
чесно кажучи я не думаю що підкріплення
могло би рухатися так швидко як рухалися
вагнерівці у день їхньої спроби закуту
по-перше у нас не вистачає транспорту
для важкої техніки великих вантажівок
які можуть перевозити велику броньовану
техніку по дорогах досі є проблема
перетину кордонів навіть між країнами ЄС
і країнами НАТО ми досі не ухвалили
остаточного рішення щодо еквівалента
Шенгенської зони крім того всі повинні
пам'ятати що усе це відбуватиметься в
кризових умовах коли не буде якихось
особливих пріоритетів у суботі
пересування залізницею чи автошляхами 24
години на добу тому ми не зможемо просу
ватися достатньо швидко
Ми не можемо рухатися достатньо швидко
для підкріплення це те про що говорили
країни Балтії зокрема що торік прем'єрка
Естонії каякалас якби зараз Росія
захотіла рушити на країни Балтії чи може
вона захопити балтійські столиці чи
Варшаву наприклад Чи будь-яку іншу
країну яку вони захочуть взяти за кілька
днів до того як НАТО зможе туди
дістатися і дати їм віці
Я не вірю що вони зможуть захопити
Естонію Латвію чи Литву але без сумніву
вони можуть завдати величезної шкоди
вони можуть захопити частини цих країн і
я пам'ятаю як Прем'єр какая каллас торік
говорила що з огляду на розмір її країни
багато території може опинитися під
контролем Росії за кілька днів навіть
якщо НАТО зрештою зможе відштовхнути
росіян назад і як вона зазначила ми
знаємо що відбувається в селах містах
які знаходяться під контролем Росії Отже
східних членів Альянсу хвилює не те чи
врешті-решт зможе дати віці ж загарбнику
їх хвилює те скільки шкоди може завдати
Росія за ці перші кілька днів Ось чому
існує занепокоєння щодо недостатнього
потенціалу який уже розміщено на
передньому фланзі а також щодо того
скільки часу знадобиться для переміщення
людей техніки та важких вантажів на
кшталт боєприпасів до країн Балтії
тобто Україна не стала поштовхом для
НАТО щоб владнати ці речі я знаю вас вже
10 чи 8 років і ви говорите про це з
першої хвилини коли я вас зустріла
мовляв Ми не можемо рухатися достатньо
швидко це ще досі так
я думаю що все ще є нерозуміння того
чому це важливо Я маю на увазі що
йдеться не про те що полегшити навчання
військам США чи німецького бундесверу це
про стримування йдеться про те що
продемонструвати росіянам ми можемо
рухатися так само швидко або і швидше за
них щоб дістатися до потрібного місця
сказати що мовляв не думайте що ви
зможете потрапити в сувальський коридор
раніше ніж ми тож йдеться про
стримування про гарантування нашим
партнерам іншої опції ніж визвольна
компанія Я думаю що люди все ще не
вірять що існує така проблема ви навіть
не можете пересуватися колоною всередині
Німеччини без спеціального дозволу тому
що для переходу з однієї Федеральної
Землі до іншої потрібні додаткові
дозволи Отже йдеться про правила та
норми А також про фактичну спроможність
не вистачить залізничних вагонів щоб
одночасно переміщати по всій Європі
більше ніж півтори бронетанкові бригади
але півтори бригади - це ніщо в
порівнянні з тим що нам було би потрібно
перевезення важкої техніки також досить
нудна тема про на техніка їде по
гусеницях на трасі 20-30 кілометрів за
годину а на борту вантажівки це буде
80-100 км/год таких вантажівок не
вистачає
Отже ви кажете що треба переконати
росіян що вони не можуть досягти цього
швидше але зараз я чую від вас що вони
могли би дістатися туди швидше
саме Так зараз звичайно ми набагато
краще підготовлені в плані того що Ми
розмістили додаткові сили в Естонії
Латвії та Литві бойові групи набагато
краще вони краще інтегровані в бригади
країн на території яких вони розташовані
але залежно від того який тип атаки ми
можемо побачити з боку Росії цього буде
недостатньо щоб повністю зупинити їх
перш ніж з'явиться підкріплення і тому
небезпека того що Росія зробить ще один
жахливий прорахунок полягає в тому що
вони вважають що можуть захопити значну
частину балтійських країн а потім Кремль
скаже нам ви ж не хочете вести з нами
ядерну Війну за шматок Естонії чи Литви
Ось у цьому небезпека
ви руками використовували термін
військові зміни аби спонукати можуть
бути спроможним реагувати швидше чому
Україна чому реальна війна так близько
до кордонів НАТО не стала поштовхом до
цих змін
Я не знаю чи ми все ще маємо цю проблему
але це не те що може вирішити НАТО чи
лише якась Одна країна Європейський Союз
має бути тут ключовим оскільки він надає
інфраструктуру а також встановлює
правила і норми я мав Великі сподівання
коли створили проєкт pesco для
військової мобільності але я спостерігав
як сума грошей виділена на це стрімко
впала вже після першого року і тому це
просто немає того ефекту якого хотілося
приміром США переміщували боєприпаси зі
складу в Німеччині щоб доставити їх до
жешувао Польщі а далі перемістити в
Україну але виявилося що легше та швидше
доставляти їх напряму зі штатів аніж
відправляти через Німеччину оскільки Це
займало більше часу неймовірно але це
факт І тому я думаю доки всі не
зрозуміють що це в інтересах Альянсу для
стримування загроз це і надалі
розглядатиметься як якась бюрократична
справа
але є всі ці великі навчання запаси
нарощуються можливості в союзників та
якщо вони мають логістичні обмеження це
видається марним
цікаво те що ці маневри які ми проводимо
зазвичай плануються раз на два роки Отже
ви отримуєте усі дозволи залізничні
активи та у разі швидких дій ми б усі
зіткнулися з різними типами перешкод Я
думаю що головнокомандувач військами США
в Європі генерал каволі зробив щось Що
дійсно буде дуже корисним це зробив
Альянс під його керівництвом Ми нарешті
затвердили регіональні плани як ми
будемо оборонятися на окремих ділянках і
головне північноатлантична рада схвалила
ці плани знаєте одна з речей яку я
відстоював деякий час тому коли наш
колишній президент тиснув на Німеччину
щодо витрат на оборону я сказав дивіться
Нам не потрібно від Німеччини ще більше
танків Нам потрібно більше потягів Чому
б не розрахувати інвестиції та
невдосконалити залізничні можливості
порахуйте це якось до тих двох відсотків
Щоб стимулювати збільшення пропускної
здатності залізниці тому що залізниця
справді є ключовою і це не провини
одного народу проєкт трейл Балтика який
мав з’єднати три балтійські країни з
європейською залізничної системи такої
школою яка сприяла б швидкому руху
поїздів аж до Естонії сильно відстає на
роки Отже країна Балтії Тут також є над
чим працювати
і Частина цих грошей зараз напевно піде
на допомогу Україні Я маю на увазі що
модернізація автомагістралей в Естонії
зараз призупинена через їхні витрати на
Україну Тому зараз важко розподілити
ресурси Але якщо ми всі про це знаємо То
Росія також знає про це Хіба це не
величезна небезпека що ця кричуща щілина
знаходиться саме там
нездатність рухатися досить швидко є
небезпечним сигналом для Кремля так само
як сигналом є недостатня кількість
боєприпасів або не готовність
підрозділів до бою усе це є сигналами
недостатньою готовності що означає
ймовірність невдалого стримування тож
так я вважаю що це дуже небезпечно якщо
росіяни бачать і знають що ми не зможемо
дістатися скажімо до сувальського
коридору або кордону Румунії швидше ніж
сили Російської Федерації зможуть туди
потрапити Я думаю більшість дійсно
визнає Що в якийсь момент ця війна
закінчиться Ми сподіваємося що вона
закінчиться нищівною перемогою України
та Росія все одно відновить свої сили і
якщо не відбудеться якихось неймовірних
змін у типі правління в Росії тоді ми
всі ще довго матимемо справу з
російською загрозою Тому треба лагодити
дах ще до дощу а не під час дощу Настав
час покращувати свої можливості
транспорт матеріально-технічне
забезпечення усю протиповітряну та
протиракетну оборону час зробити це
зараз поки у нас не виник конфлікт
Дякую генерали ходжеса було дуже цікаво
дякую вам